hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easyjet
wir sind heute in frankfurt und zwar
sind wir bei der konferenz afrika neu
denken
hier geht es darum das verhältnis europa
afrika deutschland afrika und die
koloniale vergangenheit und wir sind
gespannt welche leute hier sind und was
sie aus dieser konferenz mitnehmen wir
gehen wir ein und schauen uns um
bis dahin schon wieder ich doch letztens
erst gesehen offen woher kenne ich euch
kommt mir so bekannt vor totaler zufall
dass wir uns treffen hier natürlich
diese konferenz afrika neu denken was
heißt afrikaner denken für dich
afrikaner denken heißt für mich mit der
in der vergangenheit also in unserer
geschichte eigene geschichtsschreibung
zu entwickeln
unsere vergangenheit neu zu entdecken
damit wir von dort aus gehen unsere
zukunft unsere zukunft neu gestalten
können indem ich unabhängig und befreit
von kolonialismus von kollegialität und
von diesem dass wir es schaffen diese
europäische klebrige haut des
kolonialismus abzustreifen und nicht
immer darum rotieren frei frei und uns
neu entwickeln
das bedeutet afrikaner denken für mich
eine sache noch mal was war für euch der
wichtigste impuls bei der konferenz
also für mich der wichtigste impuls bei
der konferenz war einfach erst mal die
möglichkeit über solche den ein wort zu
verlieren also nur dass wir darüber
sprechen und dass wir darüber sprechen
können nicht nur dass wir nicht nur
afrikaner sind und das ist auch deutsche
dabei gab die bereit sind so was zu
hören und sich nicht dabei zu verärgern
und dass man halt nicht das westliche
system was letztendlich überall auf der
welt herrscht also einfach nur hinterher
rennt und versucht zu erreichen sondern
dass man guckt was habe ich eigentlich
was ich nutzen kann und für mich
entwickeln kann also ein wichtiger
impuls war
konkrete geschichten zu hören auch
geschichten zu hören von menschen die
sich auf der flucht gemacht haben und
dann war auch ganz wichtig für mich hier
zu erleben dass so viele menschen hier
waren die mit afrikanischen wurzeln auch
selbst für zu dem thema was sagen
konnten
das passiert nicht so oft oft über sie
geredet und so und das war sehr
hilfreich ein ereignis was in
deutschland stattgefunden hat deshalb
findet das auch hier stand das ist die
berliner afrika konferenz von 1884 bis
885 wo afrika einfach auf dem reißbrett
verteilt wurden ist ohne anwesenheit
irgendwelche afrikanische mit sprecher
mitverantwortliche und dabei waren
glaube ich 14 nationen vertreten von
türkei deutschland bis die
kolonialmächte und die usa und das wirkt
bis heute das wirkt bis heute in den
pass in den economic partnership
agreements das wirkt in allem und das
möchten die rauskriegen das möchten wir
von nicht aus unserer eigenen
entwicklung kannst du uns in zwei sätzen
beschreiben worum es geht bei dieser
konferenz
bei dieser konferenz ging es um um das
zurückdenken an post an die idee die die
beziehungen zwischen europa und afrika
das nicht unbedingt schön war aber dass
die konferenz das ziel der konferenz war
einfach darüber zu reden um zu gucken
was war falsch was ist heute besser
geworden oder was können wir besser
machen und daraus eine lösung für die
nächsten generationen finden
für mich war der eine impuls dieses
thema rassismus man mal genauer
anzugucken
auch was das so geschichtliche wurzeln
eigentlich hat und ja dass das komplexe
thema sehr differenziert von der
ökonomischen seite von den verschiedenen
afrikanischen staaten von der diaspora
beleuchtet worden ist afrika neu denken
was heißt das für dich afrika neu denken
für mich persönlich ist wirklich das
bild nicht anzunehmen was die anderen
von mir haben sondern das gute in mir zu
zeigen damit sie verstehen okay wir
hatten ein falsches bild
jetzt sehen die etwas besser woran wir
arbeiten oder womit wir zusammenarbeiten
können um ein gemeinsames ziel zu kommen
weil der erfolg von afrika kann auch
teilweise idee von europa sein
man muss wirklich gute leute sprechen
man kann nicht über deren probleme
hätten
ohne diese leute also wozu handeln muss
man zusammenhalten sagt was habt ihr für
probleme
und dann rechnen wir können wir zusammen
und die lösung finden
also alle geschichtsbücher auch über
afrika sind letztendlich aus kolonialer
sicht entstanden
es gibt jetzt immer mehr bewegung und es
gibt so wie der professor buckow daran
arbeiten aber sehr sehr viel ist einfach
übernommen von den kolonialen schriften
und das ist ja ein blick der einen blog
dem ist schon immer gab es in
deutschland vor uns da in rüsselsheim
und wenn du in dein leben cox in
deutschland was würdest du dir wünschen
ich würde mir wünschen dass die leute
mich anschauen wie ein mensch einfach
wie ein mensch dass sie mich betrachten
wie jeder andere so schlechte
erfahrungen damit gemacht und auch gute
erfahrungen welche davon erzählen also
einmal als ich muss wirklich spielt habe
das war in darmstadt
ich habe eine banane auf dem feld
geschickt woraufhin gekriegt ja ja das
war gar nicht schön und ich war in
deutschland erst seit ich hatte zwei
monate oder drei monate hier gemacht und
das hat mich wirklich durcheinander
gebracht
aber ich habe trotzdem weitergespielt um
das zweite mal war immer beim
fußballspielen
der schiedsrichter hat mich gefragt ob
ich nicht schwarze karte kriegen willst
kriegen wir ja und ich habe mich
natürlich beschwert und er drei monate
sperre gekriegt und 100 euro geldstrafe
und das fand ich gut weil ich gemerkt
habe dass es dass die leute nehmen das
nicht das ist nicht egal
also das ist schon was schlechtes und
die wollen auch das ist nicht mehr so
ist das eben von verantwortung was für
eine verantwortung hat die afrikanische
diaspora in deutschland ganz klar als
nicht nur als mittler nicht nur als
brückenbauer sondern als brücken gehe
wir können zum beispiel
unsere unseren kontinent schützen vor
diesen vielen untiefen und und
fehlinterpretationen und falschen
darstellung von europa ja unsere das ist
auch ein teil von flucht ursache oder
von magnetismus dass europa in afrika
nur immer positiv dargestellt wird
also ich nehme ganz viel mit ihm jetzt
noch mal dinge genauer anzusehen man
nochmal nachzuforschen also zu
afrikanischer geschichte und zu
afrikanischen denken ich will dem
gleichgewichtssinn auch noch mal mehr
nachspüren
ja liebe zuschauer das war es auch schon
von easy german diese woche wir hoffen
dass euch auch dieses etwas ernstere
thema gefallen hat ihr habt gesehen es
gibt sehr viele komplexitäten in der
beziehung europa afrika deutschland
afrika es gibt die kolonialgeschichte
es gibt vorurteile und falsche bilder
auf beiden seiten immer noch die leider
auch manchmal das verhältnis negativ
prägen und es gibt aber auch sehr viele
leute die etwas dagegen tun die dagegen
arbeiten die etwas verändern und die 1
die eine brücke bilden zwischen den
kulturen wir hoffen ihr habt ein paar
fragen für uns wenn ihr fragen habt
schickt sie unbedingt in die kommentare
wenn ihr mehr easy german sehen wollt
scribd an unseren channel
danke fürs zuschauen und tschüss bis zur
nächsten woche
geschichte